On dit souvent que  les super héros sont des justiciers
Mais l'autre jour, je regardais Batman
Et je me demandais
Est-ce qu'il rend la justice ou est-ce qu'il rend pas plutot sa justice
Et surtout Batman, avec sa situation de milliardaire privilégié dans une ville très pauvre,
est-ce qu'il n'alimente pas une injustice qu'il tente de combattre?
La notion de justice, elle est assez complexe et
variée.
Platon était l'un des premiers à dire que c'est une notion
qui touche non seulement à la cité
donc dans notre cas à Gotham
mais c'est aussi une notion qui est en
nous et donc en Batman car c'est ce qui va
garder chaque chose à sa place tout en
maintenant une harmonie de l'ensemble
donc ça n'a pas que le sens habituel pour Platon
mais ça a un tout autre sens interne
qui est cet arbitrage entre la raison et les
passion par exemple
et du coups possiblement entre ce que veut
Batman
Et ce que veut Bruce Wayne. Les gens ont besoin d'exemples dramatique
pour les sortir de leur apathie et je ne peux le faire en tant que Bruce Wayne
c'est grâce à elle que les hommes
vivent ensemble naturellement
elle régit leurs comportements personnels, collectifs
et maintient ainsi chaque chose à sa
place. En gros, la justice, c'est aussi une
vertu et c'est aussi elle qui a poussé
Batman à ne jamais tuer car cela le
conduirait de l'injustice
et pas forcément injuste pour la cité
mais unjuste dans le sens où il laisserait
alors une partie de lui prend le dessus
sur une autre.
C'est une scène
qu'on a dans un des Batman de "..." où Batman nous dit qu'il aimerait tuer
le joker mais que s'il le faisait il
s'autoriserait à aller à un point duquel il
ne reviendrait pas
Oui parce que Batman, c'est une personnalité
plutôt complexe
C'est un héros de DC Comics créé par Bob Kane 1939
l'histoire, c'est que t'as un fils de milliardaire, Bruce Wayne
qui devient orphelin très vite
dans la version originelle le petit
Bruce et ses parents
sortent tard du cinéma
un bandit les agressent et tue son
père au pistolet et sa mère fait
arrêt cardiaque dans la foulée
j'espère vraiment que le film valait le coup
c'est suite à cet événement que Batman
va naître décidant de traquer les
méchants avec de supers gadgets grâce de la maxi tune
donc c'est un évènement particulièrement
triste qui a construit batman et son
aventure commence par une grande injustice dont il est victime
Pourquoi moi?
pourquoi est-ce que ma famille était au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment
mais cette injustice, il ne fait pas qu'en subir les aspects négatifs. il vit l'injustice
aussi dans des côtés plus kiffants
puisque comme je vous le disais, c'est un
milliardaire et c'est son seul super pouvoir
si ce n'est qu'il a une mémoire eidétique ce qui lui donne en gros
une putain de mémoire photographique
après, j'ne rentre pas dans les détails de la
force la maîtrise des arts etc
voilà, je n'ai pas considéré cela comme un super pouvoir ni sa mémoire eidétique
mais en gros, il y a une vraie inégalité
entre la situation aisée de Bruce Wayne
et celle précaire de la ville de Gotham
alors attention la solution peut parler
d'inégalité surtout parce qu'ils le
méritent directement, ça aurait été un
peu plus complexe si il avait gagné cet
argent par son travail dans tous les cas
vu qu'il est au coeur de cette bulle de richesses
dans une ville où règnent la
misère et la violence, Batman cerne mieux
cette vision d'injustice et c'est ce que
peuvent ressentir certaines populations de
gotham
qui sont en proie au malfrat et que personne ne
protège
puisque il en a été lui même
victimes c est que les travaux d'un mode
c'est ici que les traveaux d'un autre philosophes
sont intéressants à
étudier, John Rawls
c'est un philosophe américain, contemporain, né
en 1921 et mort en 2002
et il a fait de la justice son objet de
travail principal, hein , la situation de richesse
dans laquelle se trouve Batman
elle entraine des inégalités sociales
avec le reste de la ville de gotham et les
inégalités sociales pour John Rawls
elles doivent suivre plusieurs règles
il faut que ces inégalités soit pour
le plus grand profit des plus
désavantagés
et que ces inégalités soient attachés
à des positions et des fonctions
ouverte à tous
en gros les inégalités ne sont pas
réservées à un type de personne et
peuvent toucher tout le monde or l’inégalité sociale, ça peut être une grande forme
d'injustice qui est proche de celle
que combat Batman, puisque enfait Batman,
il combats l'inégalité sécuritaire qui
est étroitement liée à l'inégalité sociale
en tout cas à  Gotham, et ce que dit  Rawls, c'est qu'il peut avoir justice tout en
ayant une inégalité de statut
économiques ou sociaux
et seuls les inégalités qui ne sont
pas ou plus grand profit des
désavantagés sont considérés comme
vraiment injuste et là-dessus
Bruce Wayne, il est d'accord avec Rawls, dans le
sens où lui-même fait partie d'une
certaine inégalité de statut, je rappelle
que le mec est milliardaire
mais il ne va pas considérer cette inégalité comme de l'injustice sinon il
aurait dilapidé sa fortune
et le comique se sera arrêtée au bout
de dix numéros parce qu'il aurait
pointé à pôle emploi
pourquoi est ce qu'il ne concerne pas son inégalité comme de l'injustice
hein, parce qu'il fait profiter son
idée et puis au plus grand nombre
avec les fondations Wayne
puisque que Wayne Enterprise
possède une fondation, la fondation
Wayne à travers laquelle, il va développé
entre autres
la recherche scientifique
et l'aide sociale, des moyens de lutter
contre la criminalité et restaurer
l'ordre dans la société de gotham
mais ce qui est super intéressant ce
que cette activité de Bruce Wayne
elle rentre en parfaite complémentarité
avec celle de Batman, la nuit Batman il
met à profit ses armes technologiques
hors de prix et ses capacités quasi
surhumaine
d'investigation et de combat
pour punir le crime et faire régner
la paix
et le jour Bruce Wayne, il complète
cette d'action en mettant à profit l'argent de
Wayne Entreprise
et le savoir de ses membres pour
continuer, le travail de batman, on peut
dire que la justice que connaît batman
elle est utilisée pour gommer les
inégalité social de gotham
ces inégalités sont pour le plus grand
profit des désavantagés, on est parfaitement
dans ce qu'explique Rawls
on voit la complexité autour
de la justice que va 'illustré batman
ils essaie de résoudre la justice qui
baigne dans gotham tout en conservant
son inégalité était par rapport aux autres
et en la creusant  même
vu que sa boite cherche à faire du profit
mais dans le but d'en faire dénéficier
les plus démunis
et on retombe également sur la notion
de justice de platon puisque les
comportements de batman sont régis par
sa vertu personnelle
ayant pour visée de maintenir l'ordre
dans la société
voilà pour Batman evidément tout ça c'est des
interprétations et vous en aurait
sûrement de différentes mais j'espère
que ça éveiller votre curiosité sur quelques
points
n'hésiter pas à mettre vos interprétations à vous dans les commentaires et
à lacher un pouce, ça aide au référencement de la vidéo.
Cette vidéo, c'est la première vidéo de 2017
donc j'en profite pour vous
souhaiter une très bonne année
bonheur
santé, amour et réussite dans tout ce
que vous entreprenez
et j'espère qu'on passera une année 2017 ensemble encore mieux que
celle de 2016
Love
Peace
J'vous aime